what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich
russell's just trying to get her lunch
money right
i am sitting in my little brother's
old room polina's here and i'm holding
the computer in my hand
this episode is going to give you that's
fargo that's fine
she's getting mad at me that's fine
don't forget that blockpy is now the
sponsor of
lunch money what that means is that you
need to go get a blockfy
account go to blockfi.com pomp
go to blackfy.com you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
go get one all right what's up i don't
even know what's going on i'm trying to
get us that you're in here but there's a
plan that little stupid-ass plan you
can't hear me probably but we're just
gonna go
president-elect joe biden has chosen
former federal reserve chair
janet yellen as treasury secretary a
historic decision that could make her
the first woman to lead the department
according to people familiar with the
matter yellen who is 74 is widely seen
as politically
safe picked for the role likely to
garner support from senate republicans
as someone capable of pursuing
bipartisan compromise
in case anyone wanted to know before i
addressed this issue you see that
baseball player right there i put that
that's spider-man i put that right there
right in between our heads perfect
so uh janet yellen she likes inflation
she's an inflationist she's gonna
literally go after unemployment we've
got high levels of unemployment janet
yellen is famous
for wanting to use monetary policy to
drive down uh
unemployment which means that she's
gonna drive up inflation very good for
stocks
very good for bitcoin very good for gold
real estate etc
janet yellen is coming in and she is
going
to extend all the current policies and
she is going to pump
investors bags why am i coming out of
the frame now
because i'm going like this i'm trying
hey i'm literally holding the computer
this is great it's like so right this is
like a vr type uh situation
next what it is it's gonna be a
10-minute episode don't worry just stick
with us till the 10-minute point
come on i had a lot of coffee this
morning bitcoin's at over 19 000
what up can we get through the topic
come on elon musk dominate the
conversation
tesla co-founder elon musk is now the
world's second richest person after he
leapfrogged microsoft
billionaire bill gates defording
anthony uh oh i'm in trouble the 49 year
old entrepreneur who's also the
co-founder of spacex
saw his net worth rise by 7.2 billion
oh my god to 128 billion
on monday bang bang second richest man
in the world
don't bet against innovators bill gates
see you in the rear view mirror
don't get caught in the exhaust do you
want to talk about bitcoin real quick
sure let's do it all right talk about
bitcoin bitcoin's over nineteen thousand
dollars
i ain't gonna say i told you also but i
told you also okay
that's all i gotta say go ahead a 3d
printed rocket startup
called relativity space has closed 500
million dollars in series d
funding uh the funding was led by tiger
global management
and fidelity management bayley gifford
iconic
capital general catalyst and more
participated in the round
this is a really really cool company
they basically uh they launched the
first ever fully 3d printed orbital
rockets next year they are
long chances yeah and so what they
basically do is they create 3d rockets
uh it's 3d printed it's the second most
valuable space company behind
spacex in the private markets uh chamoth
palpatia and social capital i think led
the series a
um i know the folks at tribe capital
they've invested a bunch of money
uh pretty much relatively relativity
space
it's cool 3d print the rockets elon made
them reusable
shoot them up come back land on a drone
ship these guys are 3d printing them
let's get to space there's 300 million
planets we got to go
investigate i feel like we're in a
planet
that's right the people appreciate my
commitment to always doing this
regardless of where we are the reason
why we're doing this by the way is
because all of my brothers
and their girlfriends and wives and
stuff are all here and everyone's got a
different room and we were all at the
kitchen table i was like i can't record
it here so now
i'm upstairs in a little bedroom like a
little 12 year old
sports tech company hyper ice landed its
final major partnership of 2020
striking a deal with the nfl the company
says the agreement will help it reach a
one
billion dollar valuation next year
uh my brother wrote about this today go
to read huddle up dot com and you can
get a whole breakdown
i don't know how he writes so much i
like you know i love fire off a couple
of
emails every morning but this dude
writes like books every morning
he broke down the whole deal he talks
about all the economics he thinks it's
gonna be a multi-billion dollar company
uh i was super impressed by uh
their partnerships like one of the cool
things about this is they did a
partnership with the nba
and now you're gonna have a hyper ice uh
like recovery um
kind of massage tool underneath the seat
at every nba
um bench so literally the player just
reaches underneath their seat and they
can grab this tool and they can
basically help them recover during the
game
so you want to hear about this cool
story yes a in cleveland ohio a customer
left a three
thousand dollar tip for a single beer at
a restaurant voluntarily closing
because of the corvette pandemic the man
walked into night town on sunday in
cleveland
ordered the beer and asked for the check
which came to seven dollars and two
cents
this this the owner of the restaurant
said the man wish him well
and told him to share the tip with the
four employees who are working brunch
service
as the man walked out ring said uh he
looked down at the tip
and realized he left a whopping three
thousand dollars
listen this is cool shout out to the guy
leaving the three thousand dollar tip
but can we talk about in cleveland they
have seven dollar beers
what is going on in cleveland yeah
i mean that's like new york prices in
cleveland cleveland what's going on get
your stuff together
but i do like the fact that somebody
left that tip that's awesome go do nice
things for people during the holidays
next
will robbins asks another great show you
guys just don't miss oh just wait until
you see this one
question for pomp what was the
motivation behind doing capital
university with bryce hall
and what lessons do you think people in
the tech community can learn from him
and other tick tock stars i like bryce
bryce is smart bryce is nice
and also bryce uh and griffin johnson
um uh josh richards
all these guys they're all really cool
dudes uh they're young
they basically have worked hard they
built a following
um and just like a you know kind of
professional athletes go from making no
money to all of a sudden now they're
making money
seventy percent of athletes go broke and
so if you think of a lot of these
creators who now are making a lot of
money
um most of them are gonna go broke they
just don't know how to manage money and
so
uh in conversation it became very clear
that there was an opportunity for bryce
and i
uh to have a podcast where we talked
about how he manages
his money how other influencers manage
their money what they should be doing
not doing
avoiding any pitfalls but then also
bringing in
uh successful entrepreneurs and
investors uh to talk to bryce and mentor
so like we had david rubinstein the
co-founder of carlisle group
uh on the pie he said mark cuban right
we've recorded with barbara corcoran
um a whole host of different people and
so i think that
uh the whole idea here is um these tick
tock
uh kids they want to be more than
tick-tock stars right they want to be
entrepreneurs they want to be investors
and i think that they've got a really
good shot at doing it if they kind of
keep their heads on straight and and
work hard
um and the beauty of it is they have an
entire generation paying attention to
them so if all of a sudden they start
talking about business and investing
there's an entire generation of kids
that are going to think that stuff's
cool and so it's a way that we can drive
financial education
and drive kind of interest in
entrepreneurship is you use the people
that
an entire generation of kids look up to
and it just so happens that those kids
are really interested in this stuff too
so
you know this is a huge um i think kind
of
kudos to josh griffin uh bryce and a
bunch of the other
uh friends that they have because
they're the ones really driving this
stuff and
that's the important part all right
don't be tapping my shoulder telling me
when i'm ready to stop talking i don't
you don't have a shoulder i did not tap
you on the shoulder okay
uh ritwik question to pimp what's the
biggest habit you've changed slash
introduced
to your license quarantine life started
in april so i
used to like occasionally uh exercise
when you know there was no quarantine
but during quarantine like you kind of
have to because otherwise you just don't
move and it's really sad and you can't
sleep later
so it's been a consistent daily exercise
habit of whether it's bar or yoga or
running or
something like that or the sweat app ooh
that's a good one
um so yeah that's a that's a great habit
i've introduced and then he asks
question to pump would you ever invest
in a psychedelics company ever
yes i actually think i should go on a
psychedelic uh
trip like go somewhere and go try a
bunch of psychedelics and just test it
out
celeste absolutely love your content
energy and comedy guys quick question my
friend
inherited this ge stock from her dad and
asked me for advice whether to keep
keep it or sell it because it continues
to drop i told her i'd ask you guys
any thoughts i have no clue
i literally have no clue i don't pay
attention to stocks general electric
i don't know what they're doing explain
why you don't pay attention to stocks
and why you're
in the private market i have no
advantage all my
all of my investing advantages in the
private markets and so
that's what i choose to double and
triple down on you know we can't have
the ask lunch money segment be
what do you think about this individual
stock uh we don't give investment advice
but what i would say is if that's the
only investable
asset that your friend has so they only
own general electric stock
you probably should diversify if you
think of diversification and
concentration
concentration builds wealth
diversification protects it but also
diversification is a great tool for
people who don't
spend all day long doing this stuff
right the only reason why you would have
concentration is if you have some
um kind of thesis as to what advantage
you have over the marketplace
if you're just given a bunch of general
electric stock and um that's the only
stock you own
you probably should diversify so that
you can kind of get a broader market
exposure
and also um it probably wouldn't be a
bad idea
just think about like putting it all in
smp right it just depends like there's
so much information there what are your
other assets what's your goals how old
are you
what's your income what's your savings
all that stuff plays into this
but but i generally think that if that's
the only asset somebody holds like
probably not a good idea just to hold on
to a single stock um
if it's especially if it's a large
percentage of your net worth
cool good thank you i've been waiting to
want to do this the entire time so i'm
going to do it now before plana gets mad
and we say goodbye to you guys
i just wanted to say i'll see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends